gleich zwei banküberfälle halten heute
die berliner polizei in atem
heute morgen wurde zunächst eine
commerzbank filiale in schöneberg
überfallen dann nur wenig später wieder
commerzbank diesmal aber am kudamm
details dazu kennt mein kollege peter
wilke er ist jetzt am tatort am kudamm
peter was kannst du uns über die beiden
überfälle sagen ja wir stehen hier am
ku'damm direkt vor der zweiten bank die
hier überfallen wurde der commerzbank
wie die polizei mitteilte soll es
zwischen 9 und 9 15 den ersten überfall
in schöneberg an der hauptstraße gegeben
haben da soll ein bewaffneter mann in
die bank hinein gestürmt sein und eben
nach geld verlangt haben dass rückte
dann auch das sek an ein
spezialeinsatzkommando der polizei
verletzt wurde aber niemand wie die
polizei schon bereits mitgeteilt hat der
täter flüchtete dann
bereits eine halbe stunde danach soll es
zwei kilometer weiter hier am ku'damm
auch zu einem weiteren überfall gekommen
seien hier auf die commerzbank die jetzt
abgesperrt ist wie wir bei mir im
hintergrund zu sehen
auch hier wurde aber niemand verletzt
die polizei mitteilte soll es nur eine
soll nur ein mitarbeiter unter schock
stehen keine verletzten also weiß man
denn ob der täter oder die täter beute
machen konnten
darüber ist bislang noch gar nichts
bekannt dass es noch vollkommen unklar
die polizei hat es wahrscheinlich
bereits schon ermittelt aber noch nicht
bekanntgegeben
momentan werden hier natürlich noch die
entsprechenden mitarbeiter verhört deren
zeugenaussage entgegengenommen und dann
wird sie sich im laufe des tages
wahrscheinlich mitgeteilt oder ergeben
was geklaut wurde ob überhaupt etwas
geklaut wurde aber noch ist dazu
überhaupt nichts bekannt wenn man das so
hört ist der verdacht yanar dass es
vielleicht derselbe täter sein könnte
dass gerade gesagt nur zwei kilometer
voneinander entfernt und kürzester zeit
hat die polizei dazu schon etwas gesagt
die polizei hat bislang nur gesagt dass
sie eben weil es so in der kurzen zeit
und so nah aneinander passiert ist auch
in diese richtung ermittelt sie konnte
das nicht ausschließen dass es sich um
den gleichen täter handelt allerdings da
eine genaue bestätigung gibt es noch
nicht diese zwei kilometer von
schönenberg bis hier zum kudamm klingen
erst mal wenig allerdings muss man
bedenken es ist hier noch morgens in
berlin
pendler berufsverkehr also diese zwei
kilometer im berufsverkehr in dieser
kurzen zeit hinzulegen ist dann doch
schon relativ sportlich